Je suis son étranger dans ta vie
attends, tu ne le fais pas et c'est peut-être fini
les premières notes de vin effacent l'homme
quand il gravit la montagne ou complexe le
la pression et tu n'en veux pas
force de la poésie il y aura aussi le loup
personne, tu ne connais pas la route du sang
il essaie des choses à partir de là oui parce que le
népal claire poésie de l'espace
pour l'imagination, la poésie provoque autre chose
démo de Mister Che the Spectator de l'ep
plusieurs blessés et peut-être mais plus encore et le
directions les biens ont subi l'un ou l'autre
travail des fans fausse télé qui tire aujourd'hui de
boxe coup de pied au cul
vrai total tous les destins pervers bitac lo
fait de Kells des féministes spirituelles
souffle que les infos du bâton que je veux sont évidentes